they're anywhere unders trigonometric
identities okay trigonometric identities
let me help you understand what that
means
right before I give you the nitty-gritty
of how they work okay remember
trigonometry began in triads
it began in triangles but we saw that
that definition was limited right you
couldn't do angles that were not acute
and you couldn't do angles on weird
numbers like 0 and 90 N and so on right
so we went away from triangles and we
introduced another geometric figure
another geometric figure the unit circle
right and we used the coordinates on the
circumference of the unit circle as our
definition for Cosma side so instead of
this thing instead of just ratios we
took that ratio idea and then we went to
think about all of the little
coordinates on different spots in the
circumference of a unit circle so we
expanded our understanding now we've
done the same thing with the functions
individually when you first meet sine
cos and tan they're always attached to
an actual triangle with actual angles so
you know typical questions at the
beginning I'll use your calculator
through evaluates sine of 55° but as
you've already started to do we have
moved away from sine of an angle in a
triangle to sign as a function you don't
even know what the angle is or you're
considering all possible angles on a
graph right not to 360 minus 360 to 3-0
whatever
now trigonometric identities right they
get the idea that you move away from
trying to see in a circle you move away
from angles to just the functions
themselves and then we start to develop
all of this language around the trigger
Ettrick functions that are nothing to do
with angles I wouldn't even care what
the angles are we're just thinking about
the functions so this is another way of
saying that the Trina metric functions
all become their own language right you
can speak in terms of sines and clauses
and tans and that's why I love this is
difficult because you're literally
that's the context to understand trig
identities trig identities they're kind
of like a cross between like a
dictionary and like sort of or
vocabulary or a grandma that helps you
take the language of trigonometry and
manipulated maybe rephrase things in a
way that's clearer or more succinct or
more useful that show you more insights
right so they're what we can use to
shift around the familiar sine cos and
tan Cutco Tech and SEC into ways that
are more useful to us okay but in order
to like that's a that's a apart down
there
right but just like languages of path is
a the tool for communication okay before
you get to all writing an essay or
giving a speech you've just got to learn
what the words are and you've got to
learn how Ferb's and nouns and all I
kind of think fit together okay so for a
little while we will focus on identities
of their own but this is heading towards
other things we use identities for a
purpose so I'm going to show you a few
different categories of trig identities
so you don't get them as like a long
list of their twenty thirty thirty plus
my fingers you just have to memorize
they are like sort of grouped together
in categories which is why I have a few
of these okay so the first set of
categories is the reciprocal identities
you actually already know these the
reciprocal identities right and they are
on this hexagon okay now the hexagon
helps you remember in another way not
just will give the third met up it helps
you remember what the reciprocal
identities are for instance this one
side why do I sign X the reciprocal sine
X of course is Kosek right now you can
see that on the diagram because he's my
other color and you can draw this on
yours as well that's why you'll need a
few if I go across this diagonal like so
you read what I've got here
I can say this in two different ways I
can say Cossack X is one on sine X or
because they're reciprocals I can say
sine X is one on Cossacks that make
sense I can go across and I can read a
reciprocal so it's you'll see it's it's
to help me recognize that it's one
divided by cosine and use the one for
other things as well no no it's just a
tool to help you remember these
identities that I'm teaching you okay I
can go in Oland let's go let's go right
across so I could say ten X is 1 over
codex or cot X is 1 over tan X so that
makes sense so I have all these
reciprocal ones I'm not going to dwell
on them because you know them already on
the same diagram I'm going to tell you
about the Kushans identities these come
up less but they're still very useful to
know and you can read them off the
hexagon okay instead of going across the
X naught I'm gonna go around the hexagon
I can go either way
for example the most obvious one is this
one see what I've done I've gone around
the edge right and sure enough 10x is
sign-on cause 10x is side 1 cars but
that's what the only one you can go all
the way around
let's have a go this one let's see sign
sorry yes sign x equals cos x divided by
cot X yeah let's let's try 2 sine X
right I'll just do it
cause X on clot tell me again what's
caught what he's caught it's one on ten
which is cause I'm saying isn't it so
this is cause over need two brackets it
applies on sign okay so you can see
these are going to cancel and this is on
the denominator so it's going to flip up
to the top it's so right so I read this
as sign is cause on clot I can keep
going
cause is caught on Cossack caught so I
read I just read that Cossack is sick on
tan and all the way up done back to the
stock okay you can also go in the
opposite direction cause is sign on tan
you see that it's exactly the same as
this but in Reverse okay good sign
divided by sign on Clause gives you
cause okay so I can go around and around
and around or I can go directly across
and I'm going to get reciprocals or
questions is that okay yeah